Speaker 1: We have a voicemail number. That
number is 2192 to David P. You know, a lot
of people were concerned about my hair yesterday
saying, David, you were are you are you having an
alcohol problem or are you having something going
on in your life where your grooming is really
falling apart? Because sometimes when people are
struggling, their grooming suffers. And indeed,
here is someone who called in about the Cowlick.
Speaker 6: Packman How you doing? James from
Boston, way back. Way back from the North Hampton
days, please. Watching the show as usual. It's
great. As usual And as usual. You've got some
giant cowlick jutting out from the back of the
right side of your head. Yes. You know what
it is? What it is. I'm just wondering, like,
what? What is going on with your hair? It's just
it's just watch it and trying to watch the show,
it's just vaguely distracting.
Speaker 1: Reality. So a lot of
people wrote to me concerned, Here's what's
going on. Okay, It's getting nice out
and it's late. The light is out. There's light
until late in the day. And so very often I'm not
getting the opportunity to shower until 9 p.m.
and it's forcing me to go to bed with wet hair.
And then I wake up and it's a complete and total
mess. And I understand that it seems as though
something really bad must be going on for this to
be happening. My grooming just suffering so much,
but it's basically like with my baby daughter's
schedule and then, you know, sometimes we'll go
out for a drink and then it becomes 730 and
then it, you know, we go through the bedtime
routine and then dinner. And by the time I'm
able to shower, it's nine and I'm trying to
get in bed by 1015 these days and get an earlier
start. So I'm going to bed with wet hair. Now,
I know you could say, well, David, you could
just use a blow dryer. I don't know how to use
a blow dryer. So that's the problem with that. But
everything is fine. It's not an alcohol related
issue. It's not anything it's not an emotional
issue. I'm just going to bed with wet hair because
of my schedule. Now that it's nice out and that
is what it is, but I'll try to keep things under
better control. On the bonus show today, we'll
talk about what's going on with Steven Crowder.
So many of you writing to me. We will discuss it.
We will talk about the trans lawmaker censured by
the Montana House Republicans. We will talk about
what's going on with the founder of the We Build
the wall scam group. He got four years in prison
and so much more. Make sure you have access to the
bonus show by signing up at join.
Unidentified: Parkland dot com.